the left can get people to go along with
a lot of their issues but it just seems
to me that pretending that men are women
is a step too far
and the numbers bear that out the media
matters you know our friends over at
media matters
they're our private pr firm they
they just clip out parts of our shows
all the time and post them all over the
internet we say thank you so much thank
you for the advertising
media matters put out a piece yesterday
are very upset
the right is dominating facebook
engagement on content about trans issues
they actually name daily wire daily
wires right there at the top
right laning sources earned more than 65
percent of interactions on top
trans related content media matters
study
of interactions on published online
content about trans topics share it on
facebook
found that right leaning sources earned
higher engagement we looked at 225
pieces of high performing content
on trans topics which earned a combined
total of 66 million interactions on
facebook
and the content and related topics from
right leaning sources can constitute
65.7 percent
of those interactions comparatively 15.4
percent of interactions were in by
queer sources whatever that is 3.9
percent from left-leaning sources
10.4 from non-aligned and 4.6 from
other sources and the daily wire
apparently performs
right at the top there on on a lot of
that content
the study goes on and on i recommend you
go read it media matters doesn't get it
they think they think that the reason
that right-wing content
right-wing content on transgender issues
performs better on social media is
because we're gaming the system somehow
we're cheating we're doing something
nefarious
do you know why right leaning content on
trans issues
does better it's because men are not
women
and everybody knows that and
right leaning on this particular issue
just means
stating what is perfectly obvious that
men are not women
it's amazing you know i did this whole
speaking tour last year called the men
are not women
tour it was a joke it was a joke because
that's the most obvious thing you could
say you say the sky is blue you could
say two plus two equals four
but today on the left in the leftist
culture
it's considered controversial to say
that men are not women
do you know why the the right wing
content does so well
is because you can't fool people forever
on some of the most
basic facts of their lives
the right leaning content does better
because
reality reasserts itself in the end i
hope you enjoyed that short segment from
the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]